What I want to do in this
video is revisit some ideas
that you've probably taken
for granted since the time
that you were like
three or four years old.
But hopefully, you'll kind
of view it in a new light,
and it'll help inform
us when we think
about other types
of number systems.
So we have 10 digits
in our number system.
So let me just start counting.
So if I have nothing,
I use the symbol 0.
Then if I have one object,
I use the symbol 1.
Actually, let me draw this out.
So nothing.
And then if I have one
thing, I use the symbol 1.
If I have two things,
I use the symbol 2.
If I have three things,
I use the symbol 3.
Let me scroll down a little
bit, make sure you can see that.
If I have four things, I use
this symbol right over here.
If I have five things,
I use this symbol.
If I have six
things, I'll start--
let's draw it like that--
if I have six things,
I use that symbol.
If I have seven things,
I know this might be getting
a little bit tedious,
but this all has a point.
If I have eight things,
I use this symbol.
And if I have nine
things, I use this symbol.
And then if I have 10 things, so
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
What symbol do I use?
I've already used
up my 10 digits.
We only have 10 digits
in a base 10 system.
So we start reusing them.
So what we do is we introduce
this idea of number places.
You say that I have
1 ten and 0 ones.
So you say you have 1
ten, and then 0 ones.
We call this 1, we say
it's in the tens place.
This is literally saying
1, this is saying 1 tens.
This is 1 tens plus 0 ones.
So that's what this is saying,
but we didn't have to reuse it.
We could have had
maybe more symbols.
Maybe this was a
symbol, or maybe we
would have created a new
symbol, instead of, you know,
all of these had
their own symbol.
So instead of having
to reuse the old ones,
maybe we could have made
the symbol star for 10.
And then when you
go to 11, maybe
would have had another
symbol for that.
Let me go to 11 just
to hit the point home.
So 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
So 11 in our number system,
we say that this is 1 ten--
let me write it this way-- and
then this is also, it's 1 ten
and then 1 one.
So it's 1 ten plus 1 one.
I know this is kind of
strange to see it this way,
but it represents this
number of objects.
If we had a base 11, or I guess
we could say base 12 number
system, maybe we would
have had a symbol
for this instead of
reusing our old digits.
Maybe a symbol could have
been something wacky.
Maybe it would've
been a smiley face.
Who knows what it
would have been?
And I'll introduce
higher number base
systems in kind of future
videos, where we see what,
kind of, the symbols
that are actually used.
But what I want to
do in this video
is think about,
how would we count,
or what symbols would we
use, if we had fewer digits?
And in particular, how
would we count things
if we only had two digits?
If we only had 0 and 1.
And that's essentially
what we're going to do,
is think about how we would
represent numbers in base 2.
Our traditional number system
is a base 10 number system.
We have 10 digits, 0 through 9.
How would we count in base 2?
So if you have zero things,
you'd still probably say,
hey, I have zero, I
can use the digit 0.
If I have one thing,
I could still say,
hey, I have one thing, because
we have the digits 0 and 1.
So let me make it clear.
The digits here, the digits
in base 2 can be 0 or 1.
So if I have one thing, I
can still use the number 1.
But now all of a sudden, I
have these two objects here,
and I'm saying that I'm limited
to only these two digits
over here.
So how could I represent it?
Well, instead of
having a tens place,
I could create a twos place.
And I know it might sound a
little bit counterintuitive,
but I think you'll get
used to it a little bit.
So over here in base 10, we
said we had 1 ten and 0 ones.
So in base 2, why can't we say
that we have 1 two and 0 ones?
Let me make that clear.
So this right here is
saying 1 two and 0 ones.
I want to make sure you
understand the analogy here.
In base 10-- let me write
a larger number in base 10.
So if I write the
number 256 in base 10.
So this is base 10 over here.
What is this saying?
This is saying 2 hundreds,
so 2 times 100-- or maybe
I should write down
the word, because I
don't want to confuse the
symbols-- 2 hundreds plus 5
times, or maybe I
should say, 2 hundreds
plus 5 tens plus 6 ones.
That's what I represent here.
And the way we know
that, is that we
know that if we go two
places to the left,
this is the hundreds place.
This is the tens place.
And this is the ones place.
And if you know
from your exponents,
this is equal to 10 times 10.
This right here is equal to
10 times itself only once.
And this is equal
to 10 times itself,
I guess you could
call it, zero times.
Or if you know your exponents,
this is 10 to the second power.
This is 10 to the
first power place.
And this is 10 to
the 0-th power place.
And if you added
another digit here,
that would be the
thousands place,
which would be 10
times 10 times 10.
We're going to do the
exact same thing in base 2,
but instead of using 10,
we're going to use 2.
So now this is the twos place.
This is the twos
place over here.
This is the ones place.
If we add more digits
let me make it clear.
So in base 2, let me write
a number here in base 2.
And remember, in base 2 I
can only use zeroes and ones.
So in base 2 maybe I
have the number 1010.
So when you think about it
this way, if this was base 10,
you would call this the tens
place, the hundreds place,
and the thousands place.
But this is base 2 now.
So let me be very clear.
We are only using two digits.
So in base 2, this right here,
this is still the ones place.
Now this is going to
be the twos place.
Remember in base 10
this was the tens place.
Now this is the twos place.
Now this would be, and you
could take a guess here,
hundreds was 10 times 10.
When we go two spaces
to the left in base 2,
this should be the
2 times twos place,
or this is the fours place.
This over here is going
to be the eights place.
So if you wanted
to kind of think
about this in terms of base 2,
this is 1 eight plus 0 fours
plus 1 twos plus 0 ones.
So if you wanted to represent
this exact same number in base
10, it's 1 eight plus 1 two.
So in base 10 this would
be-- let me write it
over here-- in
base 10, this would
be an 8 plus a 2,
which is just a 10.
So this is it in base 10.
This is how you
would represent what
we know as this many
things, as 10 things,
this is how you would
represent it in base 2,
this is how we know we would
represent it in base 10.
Now let's continue here, just to
make sure we understand things.
So, this many objects.
Well, in base 2, we
have 1 if you just
have two objects,
that's 1 two and 0 ones.
Now, three objects would
be one 2 plus 1 ones.
So let me do it over here.
So this would be
1 two plus 1 one.
So this is three
objects in base 2.
Now when you go to this.
So over here we have 1
four, 0 twos, and 0 ones.
So now we're going to
go to the four place,
because we've essentially
maxed out everything.
If we increment more, we
have to go to one more place.
Just like we did in
base 10, but now we
could only use the
digits 0 and 1.
So now we'll have 1
four, 0 twos, 0 ones.
Now when we add one more.
We're going to add one more 1.
So now we have 1 four,
0 twos, and 1 one.
And just to be clear,
this is this many things.
This is this many
things in base 2,
this is the four place,
1 four and 1 one.
If you wanted to convert
this into base 10,
you'd say, look, this is
1 four, 0 twos, and 1 one.
So if you have a
four and a one, we
would represent that with
the symbol 5 in base 10.
We don't have that symbol
available to us in base 2.
Let's go to this.
So now we're going to
increment one more.
So, how can we represent
that in base 2?
This is definitely, we're
going to have 1 four.
And then we're
going to have 1 two.
And then we're going
to have 0 ones.
And if you keep--
it's kind of fun
to practice counting in base 2.
You'll start to
get the hang of it.
So here we have to add 1 one
to this, so we get 1, 1, 1.
And now when we get
to eight, there's
no way to kind of
increment any of these
any higher, so we have
to get a new place.
We have to go to
the eights place.
So we have 1 eight, 0
fours, 0 twos, and 0 ones.
This right here, it might
look like 1,000 to you,
but it would be 1,000
if we were in base 10.
In base 2 this is
this many objects.
This is eight objects in base 2.
When you increment it
one, we'll have this many,
we'll have 1 eight and
then we'll have 1 one.
So it would be 1001.
And then I'll stop here at what
we consider to be 10 objects.
In base 10 you would
say you have 1 eight,
and you would need 1 two, so
0 fours, 1 two, and 0 ones.
So this right here
is 10 in base 2.
This is 10 in base 10.
Hopefully, that doesn't
confuse you too much.